le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
de
la rue à la chance de posséder
d'immensters sauvages et préservées les
ENS espace naturel sensibles propriétés
du conseil général font partie de ces
terres riches en espèces endémie ces
espaces doivent être respectés d'un
autre côté les terres agricoles sont
rares certains agriculteurs ont des
difficultés à s'agrandir ou à
s'installer alors que la réunion vise
l'autosuffisance alimentaire et que
l'agriculture est un secteur porteur
d'emploi et de richesse
peut-on arriver à concilier ces deux
exigences ces deux nécessités on en
parle maintenant dans les liens sociales
un maternelle est une jeune femme
ambitieuse et volontaire amoureuse de la
nature depuis qu'elle est toute petite
elle a pour objectif d'exercer un métier
directement en contact avec la nature
c'est donc tout naturellement quel
souriante vers l'agriculture
diplômé et passionné en agroécologie
elle décide d'aller au bout de ses rêves
et de devenir agricultrice bio malgré sa
motivation Anna doit trouver des terres
à cultiver mais à la Réunion les terres
agricoles sont rares elle tape à toutes
les portes et constate qu'il est très
difficile de se procurer un terrain
cultivé jusqu'au jour où elle prend
connaissance que le Conseil général met
à disposition des terres classées en
espace naturel sensible à destination
principale des jeunes agriculteurs
ça fait trois ans que j'ai décidé de
m'installer en agriculture biologique
je cherchais un métier en fait dans
lequel je sois en harmonie avec la
nature
travailler dehors au grand air et avoir
un travail physique aussi c'était
important au départ dans mon projet j'ai
fait des stages dans des fermes
agricoles biologiques dans la région de
l'Ouest et je cherchais donc un terrain
de deux hectares 1 à 2 hectares disons
dans l'Ouest pour pouvoir m'installer
c'est la télévision que j'ai vu que le
Conseil Général cherchait des jeunes
agriculteurs pour s'occuper de terrain
en friche qu'il possédait depuis
longtemps
et j'ai décidé de d'envoyer un dossier
j'ai envoyé mon projet de fin d'études
de brevet professionnel de responsable
d'exploitation agricole
c'est un projet donc
d'agriculture biologique diversifiée et
il a plu
je suis très très fier et heureuse qu'il
est qu'il est plus aux instances de du
conseil général parce que vraiment je
c'est le genre de terrain qui va très
bien convenir à mon projet anna est très
heureuse et motivée les idées ne
manquent pas pour exploiter au mieux ce
terrain son nouveau terrain elle propose
de valoriser le site par des cultures
maraîchères en plein champ et sous serre
par des productions végétales diverses
passiflore pitaya arbre fruitier de
toutes sortes et par un petit élevage de
volailles l'objectif étant de créer un
espace agroécologique où les pratiques
agricoles respectent la biodiversité en
harmonie avec l'écosystème de cet espace
naturel sensible je vais utiliser la
partie haute qui est assez plane pour
mettre des légumes de plein champ
adaptés à la situation c'est à dire nous
sommes à 950 mètres d'altitude ici
donc ça va être du chou du chouchou
des breds qui peut épinards salade il va
y avoir aussi du chou-fleur des
artichauts et on manque beaucoup de
fruits bio à la Réunion donc j'espère
pouvoir planter donc des agrumes des
péchés des pommiers peut-être j'aimerais
aussi beaucoup planter des arbres
endémiques donc tamarin boîte nattes
arbres de bois de couleurs des hauts
pour arriver à conserver l'environnement
naturel et même lui redonner la nature
qu'il a un petit peu perdu peut-être
voilà pour favoriser en fait la venue
des oiseaux qui sont nombreux dans la
dans la région
il y aura aussi des des fleurs
mellifères parce que il est important
qu'il y ait aussi des abeilles pour
pouvoir polliniser que ce soit les
arbres fruitiers ou les légumes ils ont
tous besoin d'être pollinisés donc il y
aura aussi quelques ruches et les ruches
sont en général très heureuses en
bordure de forêt comme c'est ici
utilisez des ENS comme terre à cultiver
tout en respectant l'environnement est
une des solutions utiles et efficaces à
tous les acteurs de ce dispositif
et durable pour les nouveaux
agriculteurs et un avenir éco-citoyen
pour la Réunion
notre agriculture est performante mais
les jeunes agriculteurs qui veulent
s'installer ou ceux qui veulent agrandir
à leur exploitation manque de
possibilités et de terre et nous nous
avons au Conseil Général des espaces
naturels sensibles avec des terres à
préserver mais qui ne doivent pas pour
autant être sacralisé il est de notre
responsabilité au Conseil Général de
mettre en place un développement
durable à la Réunion qui soit
économiquement efficace mais également
écologiquement durable et j'ai envie de
dire aussi socialement équitable c'est
pour cela que ces jeunes agriculteurs
pourront bénéficier à un moindre coût
d'une terre pour pouvoir cultiver
économiquement efficace socialement
équitable écologiquement durable les
trois piliers du développement durable
deviennent ainsi une réalité concrète
via cette idée innovante en louant à bas
prix ces espaces naturels sensibles à
des agriculteurs le Conseil général
permet la dynamisation de tout un
secteur de l'économie agricole d'un côté
il y avait des terres de qualité non
cultivé de l'autre des agriculteurs qui
ont besoin de terre pour travailler il
suffisait d'avoir l'idée de réunir les
deux pour lancer l'agriculture
réunionnaise sur une nouvelle voie
pleine d'avenir et porteuse d'emploi le
Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous AAL
aux côtés des Réunionnais